today I can report some very encouraging  information which has unfolded over the  last 24 hours  the towed pinger located  locator deployed from the Australian  Defense vessel ocean shield has detected  signals consistent with those emitted by  aircraft black boxes to separate the  signal detection have occurred within  the northern part of the defined search  area the first detection was held for  approximately 2 hours and 20 minutes the  ship then lost contact before conducting  a turn and attempting to reacquire the  signal the second detection on the  return leg was held for approximately 13  minutes on this occasion two distinct  pinger returns were audible  significantly this would be consistent  with transmissions from both the flight  data recorder and the cockpit voice  recorder